Everything on planet earth in outer space
Call Adam
And Adam is going to be the smallest of any matter that exists
Calendar
Frozen
Neutrons and electrons have a negative charge
The protons and neutrons
Where is the electron
If you have
Italian
Bowie County Annex number
The number of protons
That's not an element
On the periodic table of elements you can also find other information besides atomic number
Find out valence electrons surround the amount of electrons in the outer shell
Two organelles
T-Mobile number
Don't you looking at
Which means a different atomic mass
For the number of protons number
Do you think I said
Nutria
Taking your afternoon
Phone number
If you have to make an eye on them
Map
You're only going to be a movie extra
Scion
Electron
Changing the element
Finally got it because all atoms want to be happy
Valence shell
And in order to do that
32 ways we can
Would be if you hadn't
Pink electrons are held together by
Actually
Family Guy the last thing you need to know about the second one didn't polarity
Henderson
How to draw a rectangular meaning of Sarah
Hotstar
How many
Because the electrons are actually all